[Music]
you're probably one of the most
diversified investors that i've had the
privilege of speaking to you've got
stocks cryptocurrencies gold venture
capital from your shark tank deals and
of course you've got watches let's talk
about your personal journey you've got a
wide
spectrum of watches in your collection
since when did you start collecting
well my stepfather
was uh worked with the united nations
and we traveled a lot and it's
headquartered in geneva switzerland and
so he was constantly
going back there we have a home in
geneva he's now in fact swiss citizen
and in the 70s mid 70s he introduced me
took me to down the roger river de lac
we drove right into geneva and all the
great many zones are right there by the
lake in geneva that famous waterspout
you're going to find rolex patek ap all
of them they're all there you can walk
between these massive maisons
and he took me in and started showing me
watchmaking as an industry in the output
at that time
and i just got hooked i mean
you know when i was a teenager i i was i
knew all the different makes all the
brands all the models all the movements
all the calibers all the cases all the
dials wow and yet i couldn't afford
anything right because you know it just
was out of my reach and he wasn't going
to extend you know that that's not he
taught me to go make it on my own when i
could afford it i came back with a
vengeance
and i but i already knew
uh pretty well all the details of what
was collectible what wasn't what makes
what brands what was hot what all of it
and so i i have been insatiable in terms
of building my collection and i've just
i just i enjoy it so much and watch
community globally is the fascinating
group of individuals
kings monarchs
collectors
physicians i mean you name it that it's
just the most remarkable and i know i
know most of the world's largest watch
collectors now that's the bond between
us
do you remember the first piece you
bought
yes i do
omega speedmaster moonwatch wow that's
the classic okay
mid 70s yes and i've had since then two
of my collections have been stolen
inside jobs but that piece i was able to
recover
um
and it's a very valuable piece most
emotionally but also the movement of the
caliber at that time was very important
because
they built some of the best movements
then because they're of course in the
nassau program at that time right
did you buy the uh snoopy moon watch
that came out recently
did you watch that yes i did yesterday i
did and i'm actually going to be getting
that
in a few weeks it's going to be one of
my shark tank eights in season 14. it
will be a one of a kind with a red band
on it and i think the reason the snoopy
is taking off for those of you who don't
know it in the back dial
there is snoopy on a rocket ship going
to the moon and the bitcoin community
has gone berserk over that watch and so
i don't flip my watches but if i wanted
to sell it i could make a fortune on
that piece but i won't be doing that
well especially since it's got your
signature red band on it um i know the
story behind that i'm going to talk i'm
going to talk to the audience about some
of the pieces that you have today to
show us but uh first i want to i want to
get your thoughts on this story i was
reading an article by the financial
times that came out about a month or two
ago and i'll just read the headline of
one of the paragraphs here it says
chinese investors pick luxury watches
over houses the wealthy are spending
their extra cash in rolex's rare
downturn grips property sector and it
says here property has been a one-way
bet in most chinese cities but the urban
housing market was liberalized in late
90s now it says here um most of the
wealthy in china well not most
but a big percentage of the wealthy in
china have traditionally bought houses
as a store of value but now they're
shifting their extra cash into rolexes
patex and other luxury brands is this a
trend you've been noticing all around
the world or is this exclusive to just
china
no it's all around the world it's all
through asia all through north america
and india everywhere
um
you know there's there's a huge
uh
movement going on in terms of collectors
that are considering mechanical watches
art no different than modern art however
some watches have appreciated even more
than art and as a result you have to you
have to honor the craft because let's
face it the baseline is none of us needs
a mechanical watch the time on your cell
phone is the most accurate time you can
get today
and yet we're willing to pay hundreds of
thousand dollars for a piece that takes
up to two years to make meticulous be
meticulously by an artist that started
their career when they were 14 or 15
years old to become a master watchmaker
is a dedication of a lifetime and that's
one of the things i do when i collect
watches i honor the art and the makers
know that i do that and give me access
to the pieces watch collecting is a very
um
complicated pursuit it's about
relationships and honoring brands and
collecting brands and getting to be
known within the community as somebody
who's in it for the reasons that are
long term in nature
when you got into the hobby or the um
the passion i may call it that you
didn't think about it as maybe buying
your first moon watch as an investment
item did you
no i didn't i just wanted that thing
because i was such a i was a bit of a a
science geek and that what the piece was
was covered by all the the you know the
space magazines and the journals of the
time there was no internet then so you'd
be running around trying to find the
magazines and get a copy of it talking
about the movement the astronauts that
wore it how the watch worked
you know it's a chronograph i mean and
when i finally got that piece as my
first piece i was literally to the moon
figuratively hopefully one day literally
as well but kevin uh watches have well
the high-end watches at least have gone
up tremendously in value i was actually
at a dealer here in vancouver i was
looking at some omegas just browsing and
they told me just january they raised
the price again i think it's happened
two or three times in last year every
every quarter or something raise the
price by a little bit it's it's more
than beat inflation it's it's just
outpaced everything else by a lot why
the price inflation in rolex's and
pateks and all the high-end high-end
watches that are hard to find what
happened in the last two years kevin
well in the last two years let's say on
on omega as a brand
um omega was acquired by the swatch
group and generally when a giant
behemoth luxury brand takes over a watch
brand that sometimes is not a good
outcome for that brand but in the case
of omega it worked out because
as you know they affiliated themselves
with the james bond brand and they
brought out james bond pieces that were
very very popular the quality of the
calibers the movements remained high
which is very important to collectors
and then you had this phenomenon of
great dial design in the last two years
omega's watchmakers and artistry has
really really been cutting edge in terms
of bringing forward the spark the sports
watch and even the dress watcher not as
much as a favor for any brand sports
watches right now and the steel format
is smoking hot and omega hit it in
stride and then along comes the snoopy
which just went
viral and so when a brand gets a hit
like that
um
it just pulls up the entire brand and
today collectors covet omegas
particularly vintage omegas and also the
snoopy is a must-have
in every collector's uh you know
well it's important
they're very very hard to find and i'm a
very very lucky guy because i'm well
known as a collector and i i i love to
tell the stories of my watches they know
i don't resell them so i'm able to call
up the maisons and make my case
and i never ask for a watch for free i
want to honor the artist i'll buy it and
i never resell it well speaking of
buying something uh it's difficult to
buy a rolex these days you can't
very few authorized dealers will let you
walk in unless you're unless you're
kevin o'leary i suppose you have to have
a waiting list two to three years what's
going on with the supply there kevin
so rolex is one of the largest
watchmakers in units supply however
most collectors must have every rolex
the batman
the panda and it goes on and on and on
and i want to i happen to have i went to
knowing we were going to be talking
today um i went to the vault today and
pulled some examples now i appreciate it
when you're a collector the baseline is
to own every rolex and i have that
disease too and so when rolex brings out
movements there are some extremely
coveted rolexes and right now the
hottest rolex first let's start with the
classic this is actually
um the previous
white face steel daytona it has the
steel bezel not the ceramic black this
is an extremely coveted watch and and
it's no longer available so you'd have
to buy it vintage if you could get it
the appreciation of this watch is insane
however this is baseline you want one of
these
um and i'm very fortunate to have one
however if you want to take it to the
moon so to speak and you want the most
coveted rolex in the world today it's
this wow what is that
the rainbow now the rainbow
it's unknown how many they make it's
unknown how you get one everything's
unknown about this other than most
people have never held or touched one
it takes a long time to make because
it's got diamonds
all its encrusted diamonds that actually
have the colors of the rainbow on it so
can you imagine how long it takes the
jeweler to make this
and so it's got pave diamonds on it as
well
as you see here it's beautiful rose gold
the the reason this went crazy as a
watcher is the nba players all want one
now
i've been offered
you know maybe this watch
at retail is about 117 000
today it trades at 550 000. wow so that
gives you an idea of the appreciation
would i sell this never
even rarer than this would be what's
called the eye of the tiger
now yes yeah the eye of the tiger you
know people should realize rolex not
only makes incredible watches and
calibers they have
state-of-the-art jewelers so with easter
factory now a lot of people buy rolexes
and then take them out of factory and
jam diamonds all over them that destroys
the value kills the sole of the watch
makes it worthless to a collector like
me you want factory now these are
blinged out watches they're perfect for
me in miami where i want to be flashy
and trashy and wherever i go
people go out of their minds when they
see these watches but that gives you an
idea of the appreciation you can get and
of course they're part of my vast
portfolio of rolex vintage and current
watches and that's the baseline most
people start with rolex but there's so
many other ways to go and so many other
brands you have to explore
the uh just the eye of the tiger for
example the one you just shown
how many of those are there in the world
it's unknown it's unknown in order to be
offered one
you need a relationship with a rolex
dealer rolex have to know who you are
you have to be known as a collector you
can go into the secondary market but if
you want to buy it retail you have to be
committed to the brand
and that's what really matters let me
ask you this kevin i mean there are
companies obviously rolex is one of the
most knocked off brands in the world
suppose i made a company i'm not telling
i'm not saying i would but suppose i had
a company that replicates rolexes to
almost perfection if i could
hypothetically replicate something that
you've just shown down to the nut and
bolt down to the movement to the
accuracy
would i be able to sell it for as much
if the watch buyer knows that it's a
replica
so
it's been attempted many many times and
where you see the error in the fault in
the watch let's just take let's go back
to the most
ripped off watch and the knockoff watch
there is it's
it's the eye of the tiger and certainly
the steel white-faced daytona
these are two that are knocked off like
crazy and i won't even imagine one
country they're done
they're never able to match the artistry
of what the jeweler does on the dial i
can take a lube and tell you right away
that it's a fake now before you make a
purchase like this anyways you're going
to get it authenticated and even if
you're doing it in the secondary market
you know the turnovers of the world they
provide authentication services because
i don't if i was going to buy this in
the secondary market i would want the
original box i want the paper i want the
provenance of the watch and i want it
authenticated for insurance purposes
so
you know knocked off rolexes are just
that they're knocked off rolex's i think
what's far more interesting is what's
being contemplated by the watch industry
now is the nft because
you you can take a scan of the dial of a
watch down at the micron level it's
essentially its fingerprint attach it to
an nft and authenticate the watch in
perpetuity with your cell phone by
simply re-photographing it matching it
to the original scan and you'll know
it's the watch that was actually issued
and manufactured and i'm very much
involved in that process and i funded a
white paper on this we're working on
right now to try and standardize the
protocol of that nft i'm hoping to be by
july have that thing worked out and be
issuing nfts and minting nfts in the
secondary market some watch nfts i've
read have been uh
selling for higher prices than the
actual watches themselves so if you're
doing this kevin what's your target
audience who do you think would go in
and buy a watch nft
so i'm a big believer that let me tell
you a problem that i have and most watch
collectors have and many people that
have watches have
let's say you're a collector and you
have many watches yeah your insurance
bill is very very high because you're
basically insuring watches that are in a
vault under a street in some city
somewhere even though you may only keep
10 or 20 with you at any one time i went
to the vault today and pulled out a
bunch of pieces so we could talk about
it when we're finished i'll go back to
the vault and put the back in i only
keep with me about 11 to 12 pieces a day
and so i wear three different watches a
day one for the morning one for lunch
one for the evening they all have red
bands on them for television reasons we
can talk about that later but the point
is that i don't need to insure the rest
of the collection so if i had an nft i
could simply open that up send it to the
insurance companies online and say for
the next 10 days i have 11 watches out
bid me insurance on these here's the
city i'm in here's where i'm going so
that solves a big economic problem
number two authenticity
if the nft can authorize the watch and
stay with it in perpetuity that's
absolutely fantastic number three
inventory control i can because i have
watches in multiple cities the nfts
could actually be where i move them from
one vault to another and they would
always know with a single glance where
the piece is when it was last used so
the digitization of watches is
definitely coming
um
in addition the watchmaker particularly
watchmakers that makes watches for less
than a thousand dollars where they make
millions of watches
know nothing about their user base they
don't get any registration cards with
the nft
in order to authenticate and get the
insurance you would have to download
their app give them the information all
of a sudden they know everything about
their customer base and they can make
you offers based on the dial you bought
based on the style you bought based on
the price point you like so there's a
huge economic incentive for the industry
to get behind this and i'm very proud to
be part of the team that's pushing this
agenda forward let's talk about those
red bands i know you have a signature
red band on your watches that you wear
for shark tank exclusively do you buy
them from let's say a third party vendor
would you go to the factory themselves
and say i would like a particular watch
with a red rubber band on it because
sometimes these uh watches they have
braces built into the case so it's
probably even difficult to take off the
original bracelet is not how does that
process work
so the majority of the watches that i
buy today are uh one of a kind made for
me uh so the maison makes the red band
i'm extremely fortunate but i i feel
i've earned it over the 30 40 years i've
been collecting watches they know who i
am they know what i do they know why i
need a red band so that's snoopy for
example that will be a factory red band
with the actual omega clasps on it maybe
it's the only one in the world i don't
know but it's going to look terrific on
season 14 shark tank but on top of that
there are many makers that don't have
red bands so i work exclusively and i
have no economic interest in this
company and i don't own any shares but
i've done so much research because when
you put a a band a third-party band on a
watch the integration with the case and
i'll give you an example let me find one
here
let me give you an example
this is a jumbo admrpk an ap this is one
of the most cut the blue face one of the
most coveted aps
ever made the classic now
ap does not make a red band for this no
so this band is from a company called
rubber bee but ap knows that i wear
advanced they gave me an integration kit
and rubber b makes such a perfect
integration that there's no space
between the rubber band
and the actual case and so i have these
steel lugs that makes that possible
this piece
with a red band and a blue face looks
absolutely spectacular i've worn it on
shark tank many times but the point is
robber b
is a swiss company they're headquartered
here in miami
they make the best integrations ever for
rolex's for all kinds of watches ap
patek you name it and so they they
actually have a very very fine molding
system that gives you this incredible
integration that you're seeing here and
so i work exclusively with them but
every piece i have
um
has a red band and so even even a patek
philippe this is a world timer this is
probably this is a very very special
piece uh an anniversary piece of 175th
anniversary of particularly
renowned for the black dial on it which
is just incredible and now it has a red
band um again a masterful make by rubber
b
that allows allows me to to wear this on
shark tank and i'll say this if a maker
does not like me having um
a red band i will say to them look i'll
only wear it on shark today because i
have to have continuity and i will take
it off after that
vacheron
this is an incredible piece this you can
see is a factory red band because it's
got the vegetable clasp on it this brand
um is really moving up the feeding chain
and collectibility right now right uh
they're they're they're one of the ones
that was being held back the last two
years and now they've exploded to the
upside well i want to spend a few
minutes talking about brands now kevin
you brought up some of the ones that i
want to talk about vacheron ap
patex why are these three called the
holy trinity why are they so revered
desirability um history the fact that
they've been watchmaking in some cases
for over 150 years
the unique designs of them are important
it is very rare
uh for a watch company during the
lifetime of the founder to reach a
coveted status of collectibility and yet
there has been a brand
in the last 22 years that's achieved the
same status as a patek an ap
a rolex
even though the company only makes 12
000 watches since the beginning of time
900 a year
and there's never been a story like it
it's fp jordan a french national who
moved to geneva who makes watches that
are so coveted that 87
of the new pieces are owned by the
collector base
they are rabid to get those watches and
the appreciation on these pieces in the
last three years has exploded i'll show
you one
that used to be the entry level
le bleu it's called this incredible blue
dial this unique blue dial
60 percent of these dials when they're
manufactured are rejected by fp jordan's
quality control so it's very expensive
to make the dial can be blackly blue
the metal is tantalum which is a
beautiful gray again it has the red band
factory for me
but what happened to this watch a few
years ago entry price was 28 000
the rumor has it and i love the rumor
meal around watches
putin was seen wearing this on his wrist
the value of this watch exploded
now it's 128 thousand dollars but you
can't get one right and teddy balazar
did a great video i encourage everybody
to go see it he talked about the
heritage of this piece
um
when i wear this piece i get stopped in
the street this style is all about
creating conversations it's so unique
and yet it was an entry level jordan it
just it was one of his most inexpensive
pieces
but the just the brand has exploded
exploded that's what's happened if you
like that video wait did you see my next
one don't forget to click right over
here and subscribe